[Musique]
monsieur je comprends pas çaout aux yeux
en effet mais je peux pas être calé oh
ne soyez pas modeste monsieur vous le
pouvez tout à
fait chaque année à Barton les étudiants
les enseignants et le personnel quit le
campus pour de semaines de vacances pour
Noël mais il y a toujours quelques
malheureux qui n'ont nulle part où aller
pour les vacances ils sont consignés
monsieur Anab bonsoir Marie vous vous
coltinez le baby sitting de Noël cette
année alors comment ça se fait tu sais
qu'il a fait ses études ici oui c'est
pour ça qu'il sait comment s'y prendre
pour nous faire souffrir à
maximum moi qui croyais que tous les
nazis étaient cachés en Argentine la
ferme vous venez de décrocher une
retenue jeune homme être ici avec vous
c'est déjà être retenu pour l'éternité
espèce de petit con je vous rajoute une
de col vous croyez que j'ai envie de
jouer les bébé C avec vous non j'ai prié
pour que votre mère réponde au téléphone
ou que votre père débarque en
hélicoptère ou en soucoupe volante mon
pèrere est
mort vous ne dites pas à un enfant qu'on
a laissé en plan pour les fêtes de Noël
que personne ne veut de lui ça tourne
pas rond chez vous il y a personne ici
ok vous vous mêlez pas de mes affaires
et je me mêle pas des
[Musique]
vôtres la plupart de vos élèves ne
peuvent pas vous saquer les profs non
plus mais vous le savez ça je trouve que
le monde est compliqué et plein
d'amertum et on dirait que le monde
pense la même chose de moi je crois que
nous avons ça en
commun je ne crois pas avoir connu de
vra Noël en famille comme ce soir merci
Marie de rien l'histoire se réduit pas à
l'éte du passé c'est aussi une
explication du temps présent quand vous
parlez comme ça avec un soupçon de
pornographie on comprend tout ce que
vous
dites j'ais mon ver improbables
compagnons tu ESS de mat dans mon
décolleté non
oui vous allez me faire virer ce sera
votre Rubicon je vous interdis de
franchir le
Rubicon winter break
mersieur